yeah great great so what's some of the
most compelling evidence that you've
seen on this which we referred to
earlier which is a synonym for the
phenomenon that it's not something
terrestrial it's something that's
extraordinary in a sense or if it is
terrestrial could be a breakaway
civilization but I mean it's not
something ordinary
yeah well I mean
it's a huge question I mean the best I
mean I think what what's really
compelling to me is to look back into
the 50s and 60s back at a time when we
you know it's really hard to imagine
that the technology that we're observing
could have existed then I mean now many
cases could be
American Technology or maybe even
Russian or Chinese right but in those
early days it's it's just inconceivable
that any country had the technology that
was observed and the objects being
observed then were this demonstrated the
same behaviors that we see now
uh and our government was very very
concerned about it and it was the Cold
War so they made sure to to try to make
it go away and not let the public come
involved and you know that's when all
the the programs for ridicule and
everything else became operative but
how could that have been Russian Chinese
or American Technology back in those
early days I mean that is a very basic
question and then you can look back at
the government documents from the time
and see what kinds of observations were
made
and um you know it has to do too with
the credibility of the people observing
these things as you know as general
Samford said in that famous speech in
1952 after those
flyovers in Washington DC you know
credible
what did he say credible observers over
you know these people credible observers
of relatively incredible things I mean
and this has been going on for decades
there are hundreds and hundreds of
reports
that are very hard to explain away
um and so you know you put it all
together and you have this picture and I
think for me personally it's also about
people that I have talked to with
clearances many of them off the Record
for years who from whom I have learned a
lot
um and if who have helped you know
validate for me a lot of things that you
know are off the Record so I can't talk
about them but
uh
you know when you put it all together
it's like if you just spend years
digging into this
if it wasn't if it was something
explainable right if you dig into
something for years and years then the
more you discover the more you'll you'll
you'll get towards an explanation you
know you'll start to get to the truth
which would be well this could be
explained this way or that way but it's
the opposite it's like the more you
study it
the more it becomes unexplainable and
I'm talking about the only the very best
information you know military documents
military observers cases involving
multiple levels of evidence such as you
know radar and photographs and multiple
witnesses that are military or Pilots or
police officers
um just a wealth of data and you see the
behavior of these objects and I'm sure
I mean you know of course most sightings
that people have can be explained so
we're you know once you narrow it down
to the to the ones that are really
spectacular for which there's enough
evidence that you can eliminate
at least any known explanation according
to admit it being man-made right or at
least as far as anybody would know at
that time if it's not super super secret
um you just you just see over and over
and over again these things happening
and eventually
you know there's plenty of evidence as
as is well documented and now either
that you know we have our our government
acknowledging that now we have
uh US Government involved in you know in
investigating something here so they're
not wasting their time investigating
something that doesn't exist or
something that they feel they can easily
explain
so I mean we don't have the answers yet
but
there are so many interesting cases and
so much history to this
um and it takes a long time to wrap wrap
that in your mind around all of that but
um
it's it's hard to imagine that all these
cases that we know about that are on the
record could all be explained through
some conventional explanation when
they've been studied as thoroughly as
they have been by the best people with
the ability to do that and then the
whole realm of classical oh sorry the
whole realm of classified information we
have to constantly remind ourselves
that I mean I think Lou Elizondo said I
forget the percentage he said maybe 10
percent of what
the public knows is out you know we only
may we might know maybe 10 percent of
what is known on the classified level
about this phenomenon
so you we have to constantly remind
ourselves of that that there's so much
more and if it was something easily
explainable
I think we'd know by now I I think the
Navy would have been happy to tell us
the gimbal video was an airplane if if
that's what they had figured out it was
and you know
they have enough expertise and enough
experts to go to within their realm of
within you know all the agencies that
they have access to
to get that video analyzed properly and
make a decision based on not only a
video itself but the the classified
information they have that goes along
with it that we don't even have
you know so if if that video is
explainable they'd be happy to tell us
that you mentioned that the way that it
ordinarily works when you investigate a
topic so let's say physics or particle
physics there's a pruning of the
possibility tree down and down and out
to a singular solution generally but in
this one it seems like more and more
questions open up can you walk us
through your mental models what did you
think what did you learn and why did
that change and what did it change too
I'll try it's a big question yeah I'll
try
um I mean when I first started you know
I received this report from the some
French officials I don't know I don't
know how if people have probably heard
me talk about this before this French
report called the cometa report and
basically these high-level French
officials that study this thing for a
number of years and they were Admirals
and Generals and police officers and
engineers and people like that and they
had that they had written in this report
what they called the Extraterrestrial
hypothesis right
they said they thought these cases could
best be explained through that
hypothesis and it was only an hypothesis
it couldn't be proven
but it was this sort of notion that
we're being visited as I said earlier
being visited from somewhere else and so
I think for the whole first 10 years of
my or maybe more of my work on this I
kind of held in my mind that the ones
that aren't explainable I agree with
those those generals and Admirals
they're most likely explainable through
the Extraterrestrial hypothesis and that
was sort of
the way I viewed it you know it was um
and my next story was about Aviation
safety issues and about these objects
flying around and impacting aircraft but
it was always about their physical
objects that have come from somewhere
else it's fairly simple
um and then you know over time
um I just learned more about the the
more the more what they call High
strangeness aspects of this uh related
phenomenon or you know things that
affect people's minds it's all kind of
what I said before Kurt
um you know and Jacques valet is has
been writing about this for decades I
mean Jacques valet the famous UFO writer
and researcher and investigator and
scientist
has always had a theory about UFOs that
was much broader and all-encompassing
than the Extraterrestrial hypothesis and
a lot of people didn't like him for that
and now I think it's you know we we can
see that he was really ahead of his time
because now we we just more aware of the
multi-dimensional complicated aspects of
the the way the phenomenon manifests
itself
um and I mean books like skinwalkers at
the Pentagon for instance
which document some of the things that
happened related to the Skinwalker Ranch
in which you know one of the things
that's always stuck with me was the
description of this blue orb
that went into the body of a man who was
driving a car and his daughter was with
him and it actually penetrated his body
and then he became severely ill after
that
now something like that that's not a
physical craft that's come from another
planet right it's something else and
these these orbs are described by a lot
of people uh
and so the phenomenon just takes on this
broader umbrella
uh over time and I did I wasn't so aware
of that in earlier in my career
um and it's harder to write about
because
when I'm ready for the New York Times
I'm not going to go into that kind of
stuff because it all has to happen in
steps you know the members of Congress
are not really interested in that they
just want
to deal with the National Security
implications of these physical objects
flying around our Navy ships you know
but they did include in legislation
which was passed
you know they had the legislation this
year and some legislation last year
uh that they wanted psychological and
medical effects on people to be studied
and reported to Congress
so there is an acknowledgment on their
part that they're aware of the broader
some of the broader implications of this
um and then how it how it can affect
people and if it was just
yeah so I mean
it's hard for me to describe it but I
just I have much more of a sense that
it's really is difficult to explain what
this thing is and then it has so many
more components to it
than I ever realized before and it's
connected to Consciousness and it's
connected to inter other dimensions and
it's uh manifests in all kinds of
strange ways and
some of the phenomena at Skinwalker
Ranch you have to ask are those really
UAP or are they something else where's
the what is the borderline where where
it's not UAP anymore that's something I
was thinking right when we say that
there's this phenomenon and then we keep
talking about how it's so varied what is
the relationship between them all aside
from it being anomalous which by the way
someone knocks on my door and I open and
no one's there that's anomalous we
wouldn't call that part of the
phenomenon unless there was also a blue
light associated with it or some orbit
and stuff right so what is it that
strings these together such that we can
even put the label to categorize them as
the phenomenon
such a good question it really is I mean
I I think sometimes maybe it's not clear
but I mean it's I think as far as the
Pentagon is concerned I mean they have
their their characteristics that relate
to the way they behave they have their
physical their data showing that the
presence of some object they're more
focused on the physicality of it and the
National Security implications so
there's a whole universe that they can
sort of wrap around that you know and
not the rest of it doesn't really come
into play but for for other people who
are more interested in this in a bigger
way
um that's where those questions come
into play What where do you draw that
long line I don't know you know when is
it a UAP and when is it something else
uh and I think probably people have
their own ways of seeing that uh in
terms of how they personally
interpret what that term actually means
uh uh I think it's yeah I don't think we
have any set agreed upon
you know definition of what
characterizes
an unidentified area anomalous
phenomenon and what doesn't
I mean just that term unidentified
anomalous phenomenon yeah that's you
know it's so broad we don't even have
Ariel in there anymore you know yeah so
that it's partly because they wanted to
be able to include the ones that go in
the water but it broadens it up to mean
who knows what right yeah
um so yeah it's just a fascinating
fascinating question to ponder and
there's so many such a variety of
experiences that people have had
engaging with these things that you
don't know
even almost how to define it anymore
it's not like we're saying with physics
with you can just get down to one
equation right
it's like yeah
opposite is happening with this it's
like it just gets less that way over
time although there's more data being
collected at the same time you know but
there's another dimension I think of the
phenomenon that's not you can't pin it
down it's just not something that it's
almost like science isn't the right tool
sometimes to even try and and capture
this it's beyond our capability at some
level what is the connection between
uaps and Consciousness you mentioned
this
yeah I wish I and you know again what's
meant by that then
I mean I yeah that's maybe a better
question it's but you know
does human consciousness in some way
determine
not just the presence of the UFO but
does it play a role in what how a person
perceives it or how a person what kind
of experience a person might have in
connection to that phenomenon I mean for
instance there will be witnesses to the
same phenomenon but their experience of
it is each person perceives it in a
different way they'll describe it
differently they'll have a different
kind of experience
what is that about is that because of
the consciousness of the of the human
being that's in the presence of this
thing even though the thing itself was
just something out there
you know it's it's like um
and also sometimes people have an
encounter and then they develop these uh
abilities you know not just Clairvoyance
or telepathy they develop kind of more
psychic powers or whoever you want to
describe it after that as if they have
their Consciousness has been impacted in
some level we don't understand you know
they're able to perceive more uh on the
on the on the realm of the Paranormal
than they were before
uh so
and then there's questions about whether
it's connected to
the Outlook the what people consider to
be uh the afterlife where we go when we
die
um people are studying that question a
lot it's it's
um it's mysterious and it has and then
the whole question of Time how we Define
time
comes into play I mean um there's a show
uh there's a series on Netflix called
Dark
I don't know if you ever see if you've
ever seen it it's a German series but
it's it's really profoundly deals with
the question of time travel and it has a
lot of messaging in that show that I
think relates to
how we perceive this phenomenon and What
the deeper level of it is
and so you know you can just keep going
peeling back the layers and peeling back
the layers and um you go to places with
this that
just expand your mind and you can't
contain them in a certain way you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy